Bonjour ! Comment allez-vous ?
Il est 6H du matin, il est beaucoup trop tôt.
Et c'est la vingtième ouverture de ce calendrier de l'Avent.
Aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un bouquin, pas n'importe lequel,
l'année dernière en 2016 sur le Mental Vlog je vous avez parlé de "Alex au pays des chiffres"
qui fait parti de la collection "Champs Sciences" de chez Flammarion.
Et ça ce n'est pas si facile à dire.
C'était entre le livre scientifique et le compte merveilleux, c'était vraiment génial.
Et du coup j'ai continué à être fidèle à cette collection là et à en prendre.
Et il y a deux bouquins qui, je pense sont de bonnes idées de cadeaux si c'est le genre de livres que vous aimez.
Il y en a un, qui est fabuleux, ça s'appelle "La réalité cachée" c'est celui-ci.
En fait, à l'issu de ce bouquin, on déstabilise un truc scientifique,
un petit peu comme le jour où l'on sait dit, que non le Soleil n'est pas le centre de l'univers.
Et bien là, tout ce bouquin est basé sur la théorie du multivers,
et sur le fait que plus on avance, plus cette hypothèse est plus qu'intéressante et viable.
Donc on repart de toutes les bases;
du boson de Higgs découvert en 2012,
des théories d'Einstein, des découvertes récentes.
Et au final c'est vraiment un regard hypothétique détaillé, sourcé et accessible
sur le multivers et donc que l'on fait parti d'un tout beaucoup plus grand.
Et que l'univers n'est pas ce tout, n'est qu'une infime partie de ce tout.
Et donc après il y a les hypothèses et les théories dans la théorie,
par exemple, est-ce que tous ces univers là ne seraient pas tous superposés
à des vibrations ou à des éléments différents, mais que à quelques millimètres de nous,
il y a déjà ces superpositions de l'univers, parce que ce sont des espèces de branes ou de membranes comme ils disent dans la théorie des cordes.
Ca se lit comme un scénario de SF, sauf que ce n'est pas de la SF.
Et ça c'est génial.
Et aussi dans la même collection, j'ai bien aimé ça, c'était plus dans le début d'année.
"Une belle histoire de l'Homme", où l'on parle de pleins de choses interessantes mais d'un point de vue où l'on se recentre sur la planète terre.
Par exemple chez le chainon manquant qui est vraiment le premier homme a être apparu.
On va parler aussi de, aujourd'hui comment ça se fait qu'on soit 7 milliards sur terre,
comment on en est arrivé là sur la surpopulation qui n'est pas un phénomène anecdotique
c'est-à-dire que tous les animaux autorégulent leur population en fonction des ressources qu'ils ont
et nous sommes les seuls à ne pas le faire,
et pour l'instant les seuls organismes vivants qui n'autorégule pas leur population sont les virus, les bactéries,
et tous les parasites.
Voilà, très intéressant aussi.
Il soulève aussi des questions;
comme d'où vient le fait que l'on soit les seuls à parler,
et sommes nous réellement les seuls à parler ?
Est-ce qu'on arrivera à se nourrir encore en 2050 ?
Ca se lit très bien, il y a beaucoup d'interrogations.
Il n'y a pas toujours toutes les réponses dans ses interrogations mais il y a des pistes de réfléxion très intéressantes.
Je vous mets ça et ça dans la description.
Dans la description je vous mets également quelque chose de très divertisant et très intéressant mais fun en même temps,
c'est une soirée qui a lieu le 22 septembre 2018 à l'Olympia
Une place pour ça c'est une bonne idée de cadeau et c'est mon spectacle
N'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo,
à vous abonner, à me donner votre avis sur ces livres là si vous les avez lus dans les commentaires,
et rendez-vous demain à 6H du matin
Ciao !
[musique]